marriage gets a bad rap a lot of times t
ief calls out her estranged husband and
it's got everything to do with the new
woman in his life we will spare you
America Good Morning America co-anchor
Amy robach keeping the romance alive in
any relationship well maybe it's a
challenge these days just a little bit
sometimes right TJ and his now former
wife Mary Lee fibig an attorney who's
worked at companies like Roc Nation
separated Last Summer the two share
nine-year-old daughter Sabine if just
over time now I kind of
kind of got it down now Mary Lee is
speaking out about their challenging
time amid divorce proceedings after a
report first appeared in the Daily Mail
ET obtained the statement from Mary
Lee's attorney who says she's quote
disappointed by TJ's lack of discretion
respect and sensitivity toward their
daughter
et's reached out to TJ's rep for comment
another tip is to train with friends you
set the agenda you say here's number
Mary Lee broke her silence just days
after TJ and Amy were snapped laying on
the PDA over the holidays all the while
TJ and Mary Lee's lawyers were ironing
out the details of their split last
month easy confirmed TJ filed for
divorce following 10 years of marriage
I'm such a marriage proponent fast
forward to the new year Mary Lee's
attorney says they're working together
to move forward as privately and
amicably as possible you all already
know this is a competitive Bunch after
news broke of the GMA co-anchor's
romance a past anniversary post from TJ
to merely went viral back in March 2020
TJ took part in the 10-year challenge
where Facebook users post two snaps one
from a decade ago and one present day
alongside a caption reflecting on life
then and now I want everybody to get
married I think everybody should and I
think you're better off in doing so TJ
used the opportunity to gush over his
then wife writing that he gave her
plenty of reasons excuses and
opportunities to leave him but instead
she showed a grace and patience that's
incomprehensible that's true it's like
you know you know your marriage is like
a plant you have to water it every day
it's a marriage segment or a landscaping
segment and over at GMA TJ and Amy's
on-air suspension continues as well as
an investigation into whether they
violated any company policies Amy's also
parted ways with her husband actor
Andrew Shu Andrew and I are in our
second marriage we have a blended family
we have step children it was not easy
and sometimes it still isn't easy he
brought so much love and structure and
joy and heart to our family it's really
been a journey as for Mayor Lee her
attorney adds that she's been touched by
the outpouring of support and that her
sole Focus has remained on the overall
best interest of Sabine
[Music]